in our series a more perfect union we
end to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning one tiny
organization in northern Vermont is
reuniting families of those who served
with lost medals and other mementos
Lowell ng shows us how this is helping
the families discover new connections
and sometimes reach closure molla good
morning oh good morning Anthony Vermont
is turning purple now we're not talking
politics this morning Purple Hearts
reunited it's a small nonprofit
delivering a big impact to strangers who
weren't even asking the military as you
might know has awarded nearly two
million Purple Hearts to Americans who
shed blood or died in combat it's
estimated the tens of thousands of those
medals have lost their way
this group is helping bring them home so
this is uh this is our headquarters here
what began as a passion project for Army
Major Zachariah fyke turned into the
creation of Purple Hearts reunited a
nonprofit aimed at returning lost or
stolen military medals and effects to
veterans and their loved ones at no cost
on this day in Vermont we unpacked a
cardboard box filled with belongings
from a soldier who lost his life while
serving in the Korean War
it's a very intimate connection to
somebody it is I mean this was a real
person this was a real hero he had his
whole life ahead of him and
unfortunately he's not here to tell the
stories so I think it's our job to tell
the story for just as every soldier has
their own story every metal has its own
journey with tens of thousands thought
to be lost stolen or just forgotten
about strangers who randomly find the
medals often send them to fight hoping
he'll get them home you're looking at 20
to 30 heroes they begin with only a name
then look to the medal for other clues
they have changed suddenly in the way
they were manufactured in the time
period and how they were engraved then
fyke and his team of just to begin
making cold calls once we identify who
the families are I come down and see Dan
and we do a full layout Dan Petula runs
the village frame shop in Vermont
helping fight bring the reactions you
see in these pictures to life what's
usually the response from the families
it brings that family member back in an
instant
and the raw emotion in their face makes
all the time and effort worth bringing
these medals home
home for ficon this weekend is salem
alabama to reunite pastor david Babson
with the metals his late father earned
in the Korean War
he deserved those medals he earned them
he knows they with me and that I can
share some in that kind of part that I
can always have him with me sounds like
you're doing it for him as much as you
are for yourself more so part of my
birth adopted when he was just 9 months
old growing up Babson knew little about
his father meeting him again only much
later in life and he knew even less
about his service to the country until
fight called
it takes an act of God and this was an
act of God and a lot of hard work
absolutely it's just a great honor to
honor your father who was one of our
nation's heroes we have not forgotten
them Mike isn't merely reuniting a medal
with the family he's helping bring their
loved one home that symbol represents to
a lot of these families that in their
own spiritual way his dad is coming home
to his son and he's gonna look at that
frame on his wall every day when he
walks through that door and he's gonna
remember his dad he's gonna remember
that he's a hero a lot of heroes in that
story guys as we noted purple hearts
were united a small operation with a
massive task it is a burden that they
say that they take very seriously they
rely on donations and frankly guys the
donations are often not there so the
group is dipping into their own pockets
they're leaving their full-time jobs
their families in order to make these
donations in order to make these returns
all across the country and it's just not
sustainable as what they fear so they're
challenging Americans to step up to
donate to help them help veterans in it
to help with the investigations the
presentation is so beautiful yeah it's
right really well look on the ladies
face it was in appeared to be a hospital
their time there we have not forgotten
them absolutely right it's a fairly
special really impressive prejudice and
it's a lot of work and they need help
they wouldn't say that yeah all right
well thank you very much appreciate it
you